patrouille recueil de témoignages depuis
dimanche une cinquantaine de gendarmes
de l'yonne et de côte-d'or sont sur le
pied de guerre
leur mission retrouver johan galles fait
ramène ta claudio dans la nuit de samedi
à dimanche
l'individu de 31 ans abandonne sa
voiture dans la commune d'ancy le franc
dans ce petit chemin menant à châssis
niel ils arrêtent une automobiliste et
la menace à l'aide d'une arme pour
tenter de dérober son véhicule sans
succès l'homme prend la fuite à pied il
sera vu pour la dernière fois dans la
commune de villiers les eaux dans le
coffre de sa voiture les gendarmes
retrouveront plusieurs armes dont un
fusil à pompe
c'est un individu qui présente quelques
troubles je dirai au plan psychologique
et ses troubles l'ont conduit notamment
à faire des tags contre la caisse
d'epargne d'ancy-le-franc également la
brigade de gendarmerie
c'est l'auteur présumé d'un certain
nombre de délits il présente un danger
du fait qu'il est potentiellement armé
et dangereux
l'homme est également suspecté d'être
l'auteur de cinq incendies dans le
secteur de pouilly en auxois dans la
nuit du 22 au 23 juin
suspecté également d'avoir tiré les
coups de feu contre le temple des mille
bouddhas à autun le 23 juin trois
parquets ont ouvert une enquête contre
le fugitif actuellement l'individu se
cacherait dans l'yonne dans le secteur
d'ancy le franc et vidéos son attitude
pour l'instant c'est plutôt de se terrer
le jour et d'essayer de commettre des
exactions la nuit donc nous serons
présents de jour comme de nuit pour
essayer de mettre fin à cette cavale
afin qu'elle n'est pas des conséquences
plus fâcheuses pour toute information
qui permettrait de retrouver le fugitif
les témoins sont invités à contacter au
plus vite la gendarmerie un seul numéro
le 17